New York magazine national correspondent
Gabriel DeBenedetti joins us now Gabe
good morning good to see you again
morning
okay Senate trial begins in three days
the big question is witnesses for that
to happen several Republicans at least
would have to vote with Democrats does
that happen well it's unclear right now
I think a lot of Democrats are getting
more confident that they're going to at
least have this as a public debate there
are some Republican senators they need
four on Democrats need four on their
side who have said we probably should
hear from witnesses there are some who
say well if we're gonna hear from the
DES witnesses that Democrats want maybe
we'll call witnesses of our own but this
is going to be the big debate this week
who are the likely candidates who are
the likely candidates for senators you
mean yeah well like Mitt Romney Susan
Collins Lisa Murkowski and then there
are some senators that are either older
Republicans someone like Lamar Alexander
who's from Tennessee and retiring or you
have people who are up for re-election
this year like Cory Gardner or martha
mcsalley people who some democrats sort
of think well maybe we can put pressure
on these guys to at least go out and say
you know let's hear let's hear all the
information possibly think of witnesses
and we heard in Nicole's report the
mention of left Parnas we've heard bits
and pieces this week leaking out has has
anything that we've heard from him move
the needle at all well if it moves the
needle it might indeed move the needle
on this question of witnesses because
there are a lot of Republican senators
who are saying you know behind the
scenes well this is interesting
information why didn't we hear about
this before on the other hand there are
a lot of them saying well if we're just
hearing about this now their argument is
why didn't House Democrats bring this
information up before the answer is they
they couldn't but it has moved the
needle in that in that there is a
conversation happening on Capitol Hill
saying there's clearly a lot more
information out here right despite
questions about his credibility
Parnassus absolutely absolutely
how do Alan Dershowitz and Ken Starr
contribute to this team other than
making big headlines well making big
headlines is really what the president
wants right now but I think one thing
that we're going to see is a lot of talk
about the Clinton impeachment and that's
something that when the president was
choosing his legal team here he clearly
wanted he wanted a conversation about
someone else's impeachment but we're
gonna hear a lot about this precedent
probably over the next few weeks
specifically over the next few days but
the reality is these are two people who
the president sees a lot on television
clearly hears a lot from they're not
necessarily the people that a lot of
Republican senators would have wanted
leading his team so
President Trump has been impeached he's
the first president to be impeached
who's also running for re-election out
of that play out well because we because
it's never happened before we have no
idea but listen this is obviously I'm
weighing on the president he doesn't
like it he has been impeached quite
obviously however people on his
reelection campaign said that raised a
lot of money over it and that he can
shore up his base talking about this all
that said he is still historically
unpopular and there are Democratic
candidates out there saying listen he's
been impeached but we still have to beat
this guy and speaking of that election
so now you have people to judge and Joe
Biden who can basically Barnstorm in
Iowa as much as they want while clos
Bashar Sanders and Warren yes have to
sit in for the trial that's right and
you have Sanders already trying to book
these late flights to Iowa so he can do
nighttime rallies after the impeachment
trial Oh Bashar told me recently that
she's considering skyping into Iowa it's
a big problem for these three senators
because they're literally physically
stuck in Washington in the final 15 days
now and you mentioned the final 15 days
and how are things shaping up we had
debate there earlier this week that's
right I've just come back from Iowa it's
an unprecedented toss-up there are four
candidates you could easily win this
thing and there are some more who are
competing to surprise I think we're
gonna learn a lot more about the shape
of this race on caucus night but until
then it's anyway isn't that what we want
at this point yeah it would be thank you
we appreciate it
you